All right, welcome to another Zoom call and reminder, as I do every week, you have questions
that want answered right away.
Look at our blog post on our regular website, so I have a ton of stuff in our new membership
site, and if you're not utilizing that, you're making a mistake.
That's where we're going to have all our announcements, so I'll make announcements
on the weekly Zoom calls, but they're also posted on the main page, the home page of the
patient membership site.
So make sure you look at that, you say, what do we even know what that is.
You have been sent, it's your patient of ours, you have been sent an invite.
So search your email that you use with the clinic for either input or cutters, clinic.com
or a membership, or something like that, and you should find that invite, and you need
to create a password, your username will be your email, your main email, your password
is something you create, if you forget your password, you can just ask it or do password.
But you should be using the membership site.
The membership site is where you're going to see a announcements, so I will make announcements
as new things come up on our Zoom calls, which I'm going to do right now.
So number one, use the members only site to see all announcements, please.
Number two, we added a new Zoom call on Mondays at noon with Ann, next week will be her
first one, see details on the members only site.
It's just a Q&A Zoom call with Ann on Mondays at noon, that's central time, all the details
are on the members only site.
You do register for that, just like you registered for this one, then you'll get email reminders
every Monday or whatever the Zoom sends out their reminders, and you'll get the log in details.
So look at the members site for that, new information.
We don't have a submit questions for Ann, for me, that's something we'll decide whether
we're going to add them.
We also added a page on genetic reviews, we are now doing all these via Zoom call on Thursdays
at 2, so if you did not have your genetic review yet, don't worry, just wait until we tell
you that your genetic information is back.
So don't jump on this Zoom call next Thursday at 2, she's not doing it tomorrow.
I think it's the next Thursday, the first one, do not jump on it until you get your genetics
back.
I'll ask you just to jump on it.
So then lastly, there will be no Zoom call next week, I'm going to take a few days off,
and there will be no Zoom call next week, this will be the first Zoom call that we missed.
I think I missed four Zoom calls in five years doing this, I decided I'd wait to take
next week off, so I apologize for that, we could still send your questions in the next
a week after I've got it long, but it will go long.
A lot of questions came in, so let's get started.
Sorry, I think this was addressed in past Zoom calls, but I kind of find it.
I have avoided all sugars and sweeters, my plan also says to avoid sugars.
Our Zylethal and Stevia considered generally included the sugars to avoid less.
Good question, I haven't had this for a while, so that's why I probably haven't seen it in a recent past Zoom call.
Zylethal is a sugar alcohol, there's lots of different sugar alcohols in the market.
Now Zylethal would be considered safe for people trying to avoid sugar, it does not increase your blood glucose levels,
that's a whole idea of avoided sugars and sweeters, you know what it increased your blood glucose levels.
The Zylethal that you do want to look for, though you want to look for the organic Zylethal,
a lot of Zylethal are made from GMO corn, no, you don't want that at all possible.
Stevia is also a safe sweeter that's made for the Stevia plant, you could grow it yourself if you want,
that you also don't want any major name brand Stevia probably because it's made from GMO,
or there's usually pesticides and junk like that on it, so get a natural,
as a natural pot has possible products that your sourcing could be.
Avoiding kale is a common question because I've said it in my book, I've said it in different things that we don't want to have a lot of kale.
So both green strings have kale listed as ingredients, chocolate flavor has a little bit less baby listed as last, I think it probably hasn't saved a mode.
Plan says to avoid chocolate, which is worse chocolate with less kale or no chocolate with no kale, so where you want to avoid kale,
I think I touched on this last week or the week before too.
Why would a person who has cancer want to avoid kale well, you want to avoid boosting nitric oxide levels, so nitric oxide is something that is really good to boost if you have cardiac problems.
A person has cancer and cardiac problems, but I didn't catch 22.
So why wouldn't you boost nitric oxide if you have cancer versus cardiac carbs? Well, nitric oxide does a couple of things.
It can decrease inflammation at the endothelial level in the subendothelial muscles, so your endothelial are your single cell of ethelial cells that lie in all your vessels.
So nitric oxide can be very beneficial as a relaxant to those muscles, so it could decrease blood pressure.
And also because it opens up your blood vessels, it can be beneficial for electro ED as well for men.
So not for cancer patients, it also increases vascular endothelial growth factor, so it can increase growth factor of vessels, which is really good for heart patients for cardio patients, but it's not so really good for a cancer patient because we don't want to increase growth blood vessel growth into cancer.
This would not be applicable to blood cancers like leukemias, multiple myeloma, still would be applicable to lymphomas, but it's mainly for solid tumors that I'm speaking about here, so avoiding too much nitric oxide.
Now, having a little kale in your salad, having a little kale in your green drinks is just fine. So that's why we use the greens drinks.
The little bit of kale mixed with other things just fine. It's just that why I put that in my book and why I have a video, stay on the videos because a number of years ago was a really big craze.
Maybe it still is to make kale smoothie so people are just stuffing kale into a blender and blend it up and just continue to do that or juicing kale because that was very good for cardiac problems, but it's not having such high concentrations of kale.
The kale is the highest concentration of naturally occurring nitric oxide is found in kale, and then it has more than three times the amount of nitric oxide in the same weight of spinach. That's the second most.
You want to make a kale smoothie with a ton of kale. It's probably too much nitric oxide. But having a little bit of kale in your salad every day, having a little bit of kale in your green drink, you're just fine. You just don't want to overdo kale like
It like some groups of natural people did in the past, at least. Like I said, it was a big craze for a while doing kale smoothies.
So that's why I talked about kale, but having a little bit of your greens is just fine.
That's not the issue.
FYI, I found that there's a rife program for neuropathy in case this helps. And pity, but fantastic. That's great. Hopefully that will help some people.
There's also some neurological programs. I can't remember the name of it, because I just wanted today. There's a neuro program neurodegenerate neuro regeneration. I think it's called that would be helpful.
I think it's true. Is there a foster to a coldly supplement that is not derived from soy that you can recommend the alternative that our store has this been out of stock for quite some time.
Yes, there is a there is I think it's phase two. Look at it real quick here.
I think it's the phase 2.5 supplement that has positive collie from another source. I think it is.
Yes, that's possible calling from sunflower less of them. That's in a capsule form. So it's phase 2.5 that is show you this product right here.
Phase 2.5 mile support that has us feel collied that is not right. So that might be your best bet.
Some of our products if you do notice a product on our store that says sold out make sure you call the clinic and talk to somebody in the store.
Sometimes it's listed as sold out because we just can't get it anymore or the company discontinued it.
And in order to you know our web person said don't take it off because it's not good for the store. So so make sure you ask about that.
And some things are just on back order. You have one thing that's on back order until October. It's just crazy. Some of the things.
There's one product for the one company that we don't use a lot for cancer that's been back where it said some last November it's still not.
I recently heard the term fairytosis which I understand is a none apoptotic form of cell death.
I understand it isn't apoptotic form of cell death. It's not a normal apoptotic form of cell death.
I don't know a lot about parotosis. I think generally considered a pathological death of a cell. So it does go through apoptosis but with some different type of blebbing that normal that's different from normal apoptosis has something to do with different oxidation of the cells in different ways.
I have not heard it to be used as a treatment for cancer though. So this is interesting. I would have to dig into this.
Can you please explain this process and the relationship to the other forms of cell death. Well, I can't explain that plus I don't know enough about it yet. Dig into it and learn a little bit about it.
There's one better than the other. So normal program cell death is called apoptosis. There's multiple different.
Stimulation of apoptosis that takes place. I actually have to get back to it. I created a whole PowerPoint presentation on it. And then I ended up recording it because it was just so technical and deep that I thought, my gosh, we're going to listen to this.
A couple years ago, I saw about a month ago, I thought, well, maybe I should re-report this. So I have to look into it. There's different simulations of apoptosis. How apoptosis is normally stimulated from an external environment, being external to the cell.
There's different receptors on your cell membrane that are apoptotic receptors that also function in different ways.
The vitamin D receptor is also an apoptotic receptor. That's why by the way, D can be good for cancer.
This is the different apoptotic receptors are what can be blocked by bad estrogens and estrogen.
It's not that the estrogen is the cause of a cancer ever. What causes the cancer is something that got inside the cell that affects the replication cycle. That's not what estrogen does.
Well, the person has ER positive cancer that isn't the estrogen is not the cause of the cancer, but estrogen. And it's only the bad estrogen quote unquote that gets that attaches to an apoptotic receptor.
And those are called the estrogen beta receptors, or the a-all receptors that you're still called.
And what it attaches to that receptor, it blocks apoptosis. So apoptosis doesn't take place.
So the idea of removing all estrogens, because they have a drug for it, is you're also removing those quote, quote, bad estrogens. And then you are opening up that receptor for apoptosis to take place normally.
It isn't a, it isn't in itself a treatment for cancer, but it helps induce apoptosis or help block the blockage of apoptosis. That makes sense.
I also read that there are maybe repurposed drugs that can induce apoptosis. I don't know what those are. They may be found at care oncologies site. And that gals work on different reuse and repurposing different drugs. They may find more information there care oncology.
My acupuncturist who also does IV therapy mentioned that sodium the scoremate as an alternative to glucose derived I dose vitamin C.
So they can be used for IV therapies, you know, much about this alternative.
Not a lot. I do know that it's still synthetic.
Though it may not be glucose derived. I don't know what glucose derived is squirmic acid actually does anything to glucose though.
Because it's derived from glucose doesn't necessarily mean that it's raising glucose levels in any way, certainly easy enough to check by just checking your glucose levels. I don't believe that takes place.
The problem that we have posed the possible problem that we posed about IV vitamin C in the past is that it's synthetic and it's simply a squirmic acid. The sodium the scoremate is just another form of the squirmic acid.
So that's not really a solve to that problem can't get whole food vitamin C in an IV for that would probably never be possible.
Also, someone is avoided any type of glucose derived high dose C and looking for initial functional support for neuropathy.
Would you recommend any other supportive IV therapies without C such as B vitamins?
Well, the B vitamins that are given in IV centers are all synthetic too.
And that's a concern might as well. I think actually the B12 is cyanocommolomy, which is not really good at all.
And they may have a hydroxychobolomy, which would be good.
If they're using a methylchobolomy, this is the B12. So chobolomy is B12. It's linked to something.
If it's linked to a cyanobolicule, then that's highly synthetic and not recommended. If it's linked to a methyl group.
That's what's typically recommended for non cancer patients, because methyl groups can be people can have deficiencies in methyl groups.
And when the MTHFR, genetic slip defect was discovered, that's was a piece of the genetic complex that takes folate to end up making your B vitamins and methyl groups through the whole methyl cycle.
So everybody was hot trotted adding methyl groups to their vitamin B. So they changed all their vitamin B complexes to methyl tetrahydrofolate for the folic acid, which is much better than folic acid.
And they changed their B12 to methylchobolomy versus cyanocobolomy or hydroxychobolomy or adenosylchobolomy.
That's all good and great, because if people have a MTHFR defect, they need more methyl groups, but it's not so good and great.
Because as you learn more about genetics, you learn that too much methyl groups, even for someone who doesn't have cancer, drives other pathways.
One of the pathways that too much methyl groups drives is the biopter in pathway, where you make all your neurotransmitters.
So people can, and if you have any type of mood disorders at all, which how many people have that today, you know, with anxiety or depression or OCD or all sorts of different things.
And we probably, everybody probably has some form of that to excess methyl groups can drive that pathway, you can get a surge of serotonin and have rage issues and anger issues or surge of dopamine that have different issues or
glutamates and have OCD issues. We just a lot of different issues with that. So I've never been a fan, as you learn more about genetics, we don't just look at one gene defect to treat the person, because you can, you can cause more problems than not.
And then it further gets complicated when you have a diagnosis of cancer, because one of the things methyl groups do is they silence genes and we don't want to, we want to be careful with excess methyl groups, we don't want to silence our tumor suppressor genes.
Long story to say, not a big fan of IV vitamins, magnesium is probably fine to have in that, but magnesium is fairly readily absorbed. So I don't know why you'd want to get it in an IV cost of due to IV and getting magnesium, unless you're completely dehydrated and your electrolytes are so off that you need some minerals.
OCD sense of that calcium, there's no way I would get calcium in an IV. Most likely it's a calcium carbonate, and that could cause vessel gardening that itself could cause cardio issues. I just there's no way and people, you know, cancer patients are not typically deficient in calcium.
So if they have metastasis, they have excess calcium in their blood, and if your calcium levels are normal and you're adding calcium via IV, you're literally throwing it out to your pH of your body, if your body has to deal with that with a whole bunch of different buffering systems taking place.
But I would never do calcium in an IV, amino acids, again, amino acids are typically very readily absorbed, and it forms that you would normally receive them in plant-based amino acids much more than an IV, besides the fact that some cancers can be driven by amino acids.
I would be very careful with that. Regarding parasites, I'm still passing many worms a day, I'm assuming they are passing because their ecosystem is becoming unspinable to them. So you're getting healthy and data likelihood.
Or is it something I'm taking? Well, probably it's something you're doing. It's just you're changing your gut and you're changing your body and you're helping make them happy there.
It's not the end of us can help very much. The right for if you're running parasite programs, that is the best killer biotoxin, some things that is using the right.
So definitely you know, you want to be utilizing the right for you have parasites run some parasite programs.
How do you know where they're going? You just don't I mean it's you can run a lab for them.
That's probably the best way to know, but still, again, like I've said, with any other tests, there's you can get a lot of false positives of false negatives with tests too. So probably just better off continuing to do the right things and let nature take its course that way.
My mom is suffering from an in precinctly bad restless leg problem, preventing her from sleeping, keeps her up, she gets up every hour to the bathroom, can't get back to sleep.
It's very difficult. I do have an article on ferritin, iron and cancer. So iron deficiency can be an issue with restless legs.
You don't want to take iron if you have cancer, unless you definitely have low iron levels. So getting a blood test is for way to go iron can feed cancer and that's not good.
So if you're going to take iron because you're low, you have low hemoglobin that you have low iron, you really have a deviate, which is very common with cancer, then you want to take something like visited and or
burberry with cancer because they tend to follow iron and then your if the cancer is gobbling at the air that it'll have to gobble up the part of this and and
burberry as well, and that can help kill the cancer. So then you just use it to your advantage. But you do want to get a blood test before you take iron.
Melatonin has it really helped. Melatonin will only help you fall asleep. It won't help you stay asleep or never.
You could take higher doses of melatonin. There really isn't a high limit of melatonin to take so I will try to increase that.
Both spectrum CBD can be very helpful for relaxing.
We have a CBD called CBD's Palate sleep that has some nice other coldly herbs in it too. We get a lot of feedback on that that people really like that to help them calm down and sleep.
One of the things that I found with restless leg syndrome is if you can take a bath with epsom salts and lavender.
Epsom salts use a cup of epsom salts and use lavender essential oil, maybe put 50 drops of lavender essential oil in your bathtub and just lay in the back for five minutes.
That's all you need. That can really help calm down restless legs.
Restless leg syndrome can also be a mineral deficiency not just hired, but it can be a magnesium deficiency. It's the benefit of using epsom salts.
But so think about using minerals and minerals can be something that as we age, it's more difficult to absorb minerals.
And so it's really important that we are looking at minerals also with the heat. If you're out sweating at all, you're losing a lot of your electrolyte. So usually restless leg syndrome has to do with an electrolyte mineral deficiency of some kind.
Does there a true right problem that helps? I haven't found I haven't heard any feedback any good feedback of any true right problem that helps rest the slides. It's really you have to deal with that deficiency.
So regarding my invasive bladder cancer, writing the true right programs around two weeks ago started and taking suggested supplements just a week ago, the discomfort is becoming unbearable.
We watched your video good and bad pain and understand the pain may increase at the start of treatment.
So what could be done for the cuts in horrible birdie pain or by your escharid anal regions.
So yeah, it's you want to always when you have a symptom you want to make sure you aren't just treating the symptom that you're making sure that something else you're trying to look for cause right.
You need to be because your your body is killing the cancer. Yes, that's always a possibility, but then you'd have pain right at the cancer site that somewhere else.
So the basic bladder cancer, if you don't have your reason, if it's not spread to the re through and you have a re through pain, I would say you do want to consider is there a possible infection.
So do you have some sort of UTI that you should treat differently with maybe some different supplements or even medication making sure that you get that check might want to do a UA with your local doctor and see if there is bacteria present.
That you need to treat or like blood cell elevated or something like that that you want to look for look for a possible look for the possible causes.
I know when we have cancer, we always take well cancer, it's not always the cancer, it can be other cold morbidities that are going to.
If I was several to write programs for paid yet I wouldn't I wouldn't necessarily run the feed programs, I would rather think about UTI type programs or infection type programs viral bacterial type programs that's what I would think.
Also although I've never tried most well yet white willow bar has never touched my pain in the past.
I'm already taking several that you mentioned the page for like ginger to look at, I would say that if you're taking ginger and curcumin and stuff and CBD that's not touching the paid.
You do again want to get to the root of the pain and even taking like a pain medication all makes the pain go away with the pain is a signal or something.
The pain is just because your body's killing this cancer or because the cancer itself that you can't do anything about tell your body starts killing it and make and decreasing the pain because of that.
Then then by all means using a paid medication is the right thing to do because you don't want to attempt to just tolerate pain but if your pain is caused from something else and you just take a paid medication well then you're just overriding your bodies attempt to tell you that there's something wrong there so do make sure that you get the diagnosis what is the cause of that.
Recently I read that Dr. Flavin who does integrative cancer protocols she was integrated on the face of cranes missing lead cancer series along with me said that she only approved certain types of selenium supplements as some types could contribute to cancer growth.
So yes I think you actually got that information from me but it's selenium the thyanide which is a very good source.
Selenium is a common source of cal that's selenium for patients with thyroid issues but if your cancer is driven through the thyanide then you don't want selenium.
It's a supplement so there is liquid selenium that we use there's other seleniums that are out there the selenium middle acid key late I'm not sure what that is but that is typically selenium.
I'd have to look and see what the amino acid it's collated with so so that's the thing you have to know if it's just selenium collated with the thyanide it doesn't be the acid then that's what you wouldn't want to use if your cancer is driven by the thyanide.
Well if we took you off of red meat then you don't want to use selenium selenium the thyanide it's usually called if well no you didn't take it off red meat then you're safe using it so it's only people whose cancer is driven by the thyanide which you wouldn't want to use selenium the thyanide that's the only one.
Second note on this is that usually the dosage how much methanide you're getting it is letting the thyanide there's so many issues that it's really out of issue to be honest with you.
You're getting much more methanide in just in just plant proteins that you're getting in a totally dose of selenium.
So I just think this is really a valid issue.
Okay, there's some questions my side calls for two capsules of possible to polline per day I am already on the phase 2.5.
Three per day my side calls for 13 hundred milligrams a day with phase 2.5 is nine hundred milligrams a day.
I would if you're if you want to just get off of the sewage all together that I would do exactly what you're saying should I increase my intake of the 2.5 and then just drop phase out the fastinal coli liquid capsules yes that would be a good good.
I have found so key my feed in an inch magnesium oil like ancient minerals brand yes so there's a brand of mineral oil called ancient minerals we don't we used to sell it we don't anymore but you could look it up on Amazon or something like that.
So key in your feed for 10 minutes helps restless legs and ankle cramps magnesium supplements help some too but you're getting the magnesium right to and this is this is a good solution for people who like there's no way I could get my mom in a bathtub it's too dangerous for her by yourself try to get it out of a bathtub something like that.
You could also do the only thing I have against the literal oil is that as it dries it dries as a salt on your skin.
Because magnesium all your minerals have to be chelated to something so it ends up becoming a magnesium salt as it dries on your skin and it can be itchy it's not a big negative you just got to wash your feet after it dries if it's itchy for you.
We used to use a lot of the magnesium oil because it is fairly well absorbed through the skin but that was the complete that we got people will put all their arms and that's how they're going to apply it or on their belly but then it's it oh I got this.
It's just like crazy when you just wash your arm but it's just an issue that some people have you can also do.
Epsom salt just in a foot bath too you could just fulfill your bathtub and put your feet in the in the bathtub sitting on the toilet if your toilets right next to your bathtub or sitting on a chair and as you can set next to your bathtub.
If you're by yourself and you don't want to get hit it out of the tub by yourself I started the right last week but said send me my initial info to your clinic regarding my lung cancer I was hospitalized with a lung infection I'm sorry after 22 days of antibiotics I better.
But there still seems to be some signs of infection should I add an additional right program to help yes especially if you know if they cultured what that infection was.
So let me explain so if you're in the hospital with an infection they said you have you know strep infection because they cultured it then run the strep program it so whatever they told you you have if they gave you this specifics on it if there's a specific program in the right look for that if there is then run that.
If the antibiotics helped with the infection then it was most likely a bacterial infection but after 22 days of antibiotics makes me think that it quite possibly could have been a viral infection and the antibiotics were just killing any subsequent possible secondary bacterial infection because usually if you have a back straight bacterial infection.
You don't necessarily 22 days of antibiotics but it's possible because of the cancer so there are that we said there are specific programs for specific bacteria if you can't buy that specific bacteria that they told you listed then run the bacteria programs also there's a viral complex program which is this is about two and a half hours but really good.
So you might want to run that as well do those during the day some of the bacterial programs are shorter maybe 30 minutes but run them a couple times then cycles through some of the bacterial programs if you don't know the specific organisms that they said that you will cause it your infection so great great thought process.
It brings up another point that you really want to use your right for your first go to on all these things especially any type of infection.
If anything you can think of use your right is the first book to you're sure we say it over and over again that we've had so many testimonials about the right helping people with the absolutely craziest things so use the right is your first choice of medicine cabinet you could say like you go to your medicine cabinet to take something for this symptom you have use your right for that.
And let your family use your right when you're not using it for things that they're dealing with to you can ever hurt yourself with the right so that's what it should be the first go to doesn't mean you wouldn't do other things to but still that should be your first go to.
Is there a program on the right for swollen lymph nodes under my chin all there's program for swelling though so also ever we talked about last week about this the swelling loads under your chin that probably coming from dental infection so run them always think about.
Well what caused that thing so by symptom is pain like we talked about in the question before well do I just take something for pain well you should first ask what's my pain from.
So just like if I am a toothache do I just take a Tylenol make my toothache go away or do I have to go and fix what's causing my toothache well of course you're right.
Same thing with anything though sometimes we get the habit of just treating the symptom we have to make sure we're always thinking about cause so.
Swallow lymph nodes yeah you could run the swelling program but better baby is okay why would there be swallow lymph nodes underneath my chin well that it's like the live chain underneath my mandible is my somewhat bendibular.
chain in that drains all my dental all my sinuses all my face from my head so could be an infection or inflammation from somewhere upstream so then you think okay if it's an infection remember that's another one cause of swallow lymph nodes then maybe it's a dental infection so maybe I should run the dental infection programs there's a whole bunch of dental programs that would be good to run.
um maybe running the viral program again like we said maybe running some bacterial programs by were you with this I've run dental programs and maybe the viral program very very welcome any other questions so remember the announcements and you can see it on your screen there so I won't reread them but are there any right programs or helps for pain and swelling that happens.
the process of okay so you're doing the black sad process there's pain and swelling that can happen from that right so now you know the cause so it's because the citizen skin is stretching and you're cleaning it with hydrogen peroxides you really know there's no infection so now then I would just run the the pain the pain programs or the swelling programs so exactly
think through that process of how you would you want to look for cause oh this is the cause I already know what that isn't I'm already treating that well then now you could just treat the symptoms question this a question in my AFP question comes through I don't I didn't see that question if you ask that.
well I can look on the website regarding earlier sugar post about monk fruit so monk fruit is another commonly used sugar substitute but I do believe monk fruit raises glucose level so it's a natural source of sugar but it's doesn't it's not necessarily a
substitute for it doesn't decrease your it doesn't not raise blood glucose levels so yeah you can use it but you'd want to still be careful with the amount that you're using because it's
raising glucose levels okay I'm looking at our site right now oh oh there's a question uh here's the question I have five
two remarkable tests done monthly AFP at all the CA tests AFP is the only one that has ever been out of range
thank god if I have breast cancer and AFP measures for ovarian liver cancer is there any reason to think I have liver cancer or ovarian cancer
no so the tumor markers are not exactly specific to a type of cancer so AFP is tends to be elevated
more so with people with liver or ovarian cancer but you could have stage 4 ovarian or liver cancer and you still have no aliappelines
so none of this is the perfect sign so no if you have a tumor marker test that's typically for something that other than you
have it is not suggest that you have another cancer you certainly want to look at other signs and symptoms before
you even eat it from close to jumpy back kind of thing but the high-range number for breast cancer patients
AFP result that I don't know there's no data on that I'm sure so it's they just have a normal range that is
given as the lab level range and so there's a high number for breast cancer with that one so um so again you
know so your other cells give off these these tumor marker enzymes you know so it's that's why
there's a range so maybe the normal range for something is zero to 35 and you're at 14 so you're
within a normal range hey well you're still at 14 of the CA 153 or whatever and that well what is
that mean well it means a person can not well that doesn't have cancer still creates those enzymes
it's just that if a person has cancer a cancer can create an excess of all of those enzymes and
therefore you can use it as a marker that's why they're called tumor marker tests but if you have
your daughter who doesn't have cancer go run those tests they're going they're not going to be
zero your body normally makes some of those things normally so the truth is is that the elevated AFP
in your case may not even be due to the cancer it just might be normal for you so um
um that's just the truth so we just don't know so um that's where you say the tumor marker test can
be a good indication of growth or regression but it's if they're again like any tests that
certainly not perfect sorry this question all right well we will say goodbye to everybody
and i won't see you next week remember gozoom called next week so um don't forget and then we'll see
you the week after but keep submitting your questions on the member site and um we'll get to those the
week after you have any other dates make sure you give us a call all right thanks so much we pray
for all of you and i appreciate your prayers for us to bye bye